teens overcoming substance abuse with
the help of other teens is a new
workshop on her way in the valley eight
news now reporter Mary Jane Bailey
beliza joins us now in
stifference Mary Jane well it's all
about providing support to youth
affected both directly and indirectly by
substance abuse two teens spearheading
this project tell me breaking the cycle
ends with them
I had no idea she had gone through the
same thing as me until I brought this up
so it's kind of just like the more you
talk about it the more you understand
that wow there's people going through
the same things you are yasamine
gorovanchi and may her daliwal are
hoping to break the cycle of substance
abuse they're hosting a peer-led
workshop it's a safe space where teens
can share their stories it's a topic
both girls are familiar with both sides
of my family for me there's like a
prevalence of addiction and for her I
know she's like lived with someone who's
gone through this like addictive cycle
so it's kind of like we've experienced
it so we wanted to Target more
second-hand groups because especially
when we're looking out for like
resources when we were going through
this there wasn't really anything
targeted towards second hand or like
especially for teens workshops are held
twice a week with the guidance of a
therapist so she kind of helped us
develop like what we're going to talk
about and how to get people more open
and then also we've like talked to more
like mental health professionals like
the head of Psychiatry from UNLV to kind
of give us ideas about like more
resources if they need something more
than support groups according to the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention drug use is associated with
sexual risk behavior mental health
suicide risks and violence we know these
kids at either they have like parents or
friends um who have gone through like
addictive cycles that they're more
likely to also fall in that same pattern
so educating them on how it can happen
how to make sure you don't fall in that
same pattern we're trying to break that
cycle
now these workshops are made possible
due to a grant from the dragon Kim
Foundation the teens hope to continue
the workshop even after funding runs out
the workshop is twice a week until July
27th Mary Jane thank you and as Mary
Jane said the workshops will take place
at the coop South Tuesdays and Thursdays
on Edmond street right near ocendo those
are groups open to middle and high
schoolers who are either personally
dealing with addiction or have a loved
one whose addiction is impacting them